uh john boyega star wars actor yes and
you tweeted with them
yes so he was complaining that disney is
not using black people
like the way they should it's just kind
of like they're parading them like
they're going to be a part of this
character died off he was upset was it
did it die offer they get cut i don't
even i don't
know this is what happened john boyega
who who i think is a good actor
do i think he's um the next series or
sir lawrence olivier no i think he's a
good actor good looking kid
he's done some good stuff has a nice
career so far i think he's a good actor
he gets cast uh as the what what was
supposed to be a very big part in star
wars
which right away you have cache to work
in films and tv
for the next 10 years of your life
that's like if you're on the poster of a
star
wars movie the main dude i don't care if
your your part was supposed to be in
every scene and it was cut down to 20
scenes
if you're on that poster that is credit
yes to your career yes
you can literally get things made
because of that yes this is a humongous
deal
he was in i think one or two of them
maybe three of them i don't [ __ ] with
star wars i don't [ __ ] with demons i
don't [ __ ] with lightning i don't [ __ ]
with anything i saw chewbacca when i was
a kid
that's it i'm done i'm not going to see
you know
for this i'm done i'm out but but so he
said this thing on in an interview i
read the interview
and i tweeted at him i was like yo as an
actor
uh we are i i'm paraphrasing what i said
i said yo this is
exactly what i said so yo my man you
have done so much in such a short period
of time congratulations but you're not
the first actor
to have an unnuanced uh you're but
you're not the first actor to have an
unnuanced character
in a star wars movie hashtag benicio del
toro welcome to show business
[ __ ] doesn't always go your way and then
he said did you read the article
uh uh thanks for the additional list
thanks for the addition a little
additional name to my list talking about
benicio
you struggle with reading no but i can't
see it and then i tweeted back i was
like
yeah i read the article that's why i
tweeted at you it's show business things
don't always work out your way
uh the way you plan it happens to all of
us all of us
all actors all of us again be grateful
for all you've done
which is a lot more than tons of great
actors of all races
who've also had roles cut out and will
continue to
the point is is uh and then this turned
into a racial thing
you're telling us racial because
everything's [ __ ] racial
you're telling a black man to be
grateful how dare you talk to a black
man like this
and i was talking to him as an actor i'm
kicking it to him like this first of all
you ain't denzel you ain't you you
you're not [ __ ] showing but you're a
nice
actor you're good you don't pop no
disrespect he's good he'll have a great
career he's good look he's a good actor
he's not [ __ ] he's not robert de niro
in his prime he's not tupac and juice
yeah he's a good actor
okay and and i've had roles cut down
every actor there's not one actor alive
who can say oh i did this movie and they
cut down certain scenes i did this show
and they
it's you're not the director of the
producer yet that's the business but i
also think you have a good
reference and uh platform to talk from
because how long you been acting
30 years 30 years 30 years and and you
were talking to him as like
i just said it as an actor it's this
isn't a race thing it turned into this
whole race thing you're telling a black
man to be grateful
and then so then i tell those people
that say that to me you know what my
standard line
is suck my dick that's fair suck my
[ __ ] dick
go [ __ ] yourself it's either suck my
dick or go [ __ ] yourself because you're
turning this into a racing i'm kicking
it to them as an actor they're reaching
you're reaching they're reaching and i
made it clear and actually proofread
what
what i wrote which is uh doesn't happen
99.9 percent of the time when you wanted
to though because i was clear because i
knew when i i said it happens to all of
us
of all races yes and somehow some way it
turns into a race thing which is [ __ ]
well people have no idea go suck my
[ __ ] twitter dick
suck this twitter dick i don't even see
it i don't i don't even entertain you
you're not even on there right no i mean
i'm on there you pop in for a deliberate
reason i
i post whatever my shows or what i'm
doing
so what would be your tweet for michael
rapport co-hosting
re read it to me out loud go ahead uh
come up with it right now
come up with a right go ahead i want to
see if it's if it's acceptable and
exciting
enough i i would post that and go hey
what's the name john boyega
what's going on you don't know how to
say a black man's name
you're [ __ ] racist well i just say
hey hey john
rap suck come come co-host no that's not
gonna work
go again i wanna know what the tweet's
gonna say to get the [ __ ] fans get
the followers are you better at me you
[ __ ]
well i always at you okay go ahead uh
on the next fighter in the cage let's
find the kid
rap gives this hot take on the clippers
winning the nba championship that's not
going to bring anybody to watch
see god damn it and are you happy with
that take no i'm not the clippers
oh my god go all right what else you got
man what else you got i got a [ __ ]
heart out here
all right when i get off stage at the
lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song